[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in
shaquille o'neal uh wednesday night the
nba legend enters the ring the
all elite wrestling taking on the former
tnt champ cody rhodes
in a mixed tag team match on aew
dynamite live on tnt at 8 eastern
are you nervous about this jack how do
you prepare for
all i love all the this enforcement
patches that you have looks great
thank you city of garfield alabama
sheriffs that's awesome uh am i nervous
no i don't get nervous
but how do you prepare for this you just
go in and you fight
it's just like it's just like basketball
like i'm i'm sticking to my strengths
he's a little bit more acrobatic i'm a
lot more power so if i get a hold of him
i'm gonna display this power i've been a
wrestling fan all my life i've been
practicing ufc i've been training all my
life so he challenged me
i accepted his channel so i'll be ready
who was your favorite wrestler growing
up well i had a lot of them uh
andre john of course uh hulk hogan
big show attila behind junkyard dog
uh tony atlas kabuki
you know rock guys that were you know
very very
brock lesnar guys that displayed nothing
but power
how would you have done against andre
the giant oh i would have beat him
yeah but there's the andre the giant is
too charles barkley's
the end
[Laughter]
i thought you were going to uh to
wrestle
uh big show that that was that was a
few years ago wasn't it that you guys
were going to wrestle
yeah i was but you know we never could
happen
when we faced off in the ring and unless
he's a big he's a big strong fellow
i would love to you know have that but
you know you can't let you can't let a
little guy
challenge you and you not accept see at
first i was just going to walk away from
there when hurry and kenny and charles
brought him to the show and then
oh you're scared
you take ernie kenny and shaq at the
same time
ernie kinney and chucky me yes yeah yes
you could take those at the same time
yeah of course kenny's kenny's not gonna
do anything
i understand refreshing and then that's
me and chuck and then i'm gonna just try
to break chuck's neck
so let's move who would make you nervous
though
in the nba right now is there a player
if you got into the ring with that
person you go
all right you got my attention no
how about the history of uh the nba
well it was a lot of guys that was that
was real tough
a lot of guys that are well mostly that
mostly the knicks guys
they were they were they were the
toughest guys oakley
uh mason uh
guys like that i i never played against
xavier mcdonald
mcdaniels but
they treated you differently
they play me they play me hard which i
like
i love and well it's something that you
have to endure if you want to become
great
you hold a grudge against anybody with
how they play you
or play you nothing you were able to
just walk away
yeah because it it uh it made me
made me better you let me know i had to
step
up let me know i wasn't that great like
you know a lot of people
take flight and i take flag a lot of
people right now oh you're too hard on
the youngsters
i'm just doing what was done to me i
remember when i was averaging
30 35 in that way but we always get
swept and the great kareem abdul-jabbar
said
hey he hasn't won a championship yet did
i why
did i cry did i complain on social media
no i didn't say anything because
kareem abdul-jabbar had g14
classification to say that
am i going to have a dispute with the
greatest nba player ever
so when he said that when he gave me
constructive criticism
i took it and i listened and i brought
my game to another level so these guys
now they're they're
pudding pops you say something about
them
was carl malone tough on you well we
never got to
we never got to like across my shop a
lot
but every time i go out here he would
just take me outside
but he was very very strong lame beer
did you cross pants with lame beer
yeah we got into a sort of a scuffle
they know
[Music]
because i i actually seen what he did
seeing how he did it and it kind of kind
of helped me with my game
growing up he was smart he he knew his
limitations shaq you know
yeah very smart very smart and you know
played the right way played with a lot
of passion
i was watching the documentary when he
said he used to love to go agitate
fans and other arenas because i got him
going
and you miss bird right by a year yes i
miss very about a year but
somebody was telling me that bird
was the biggest smack talker in the game
and they said dylan scott told me larry
bird told him the move he was going to
do and do it
i mean and did it so you know i was uh
i wasn't a fan of larrybird because i
thought everything he did was lucky but
then when i
i did like he i had a friend his name's
i was magic and mitch was burned and
mitch could do the same thing
mitch had the long hair and he did
everything
very good one day he was playing seven
game series and i was tired three or
three
and he shot that sling over the shot
over the back boy
i was so mad he instantly got into a
fight
but you know when i when i started you
know getting over and you know
seeing guys put in work is one of the
greatest players ever
and it's not look it's all skill and you
wanted to be
magic yes i did that's why you know for
a big guy
my handles were pretty good my saying i
had great hands right now
[Music]
well i saw where uh cedric maxwell and
rick carlisle they've
likened luka doncic to larry bird
i could i could see that it's kind of
unfair
at that age to do it though to him shaq
i mean
it's it is unfair but you know he
listen to i could tell he wants to be
great he will be great he has a lot to
live up to
i remember my second year when they
named me to the nba top 50 people were
going crazy
oh he only been in two years obviously
one of the top 50 players
but i knew i was like okay all your
old-timers don't think i'm going to
figure
it out watch this so i know luca
and listen luke have been approached
since 16 so
you know he's already going up against
the best and then two or three years
everybody's gonna be paid now
you know i saw i saw a post one day i
don't want to get the ages wrong but it
was like
lebron 36 the rap34 curvy 32.
then at the bottom and said enjoy and i
kind of scared when i was like man these
guys
i never knew these guys were in their
30s but you know four or five years from
now we're going to start looking at the
you know the donald and mitchell you
know exactly you know it's going to be a
new breed of
you know takeover do you think we'll
have anybody ever surpass kobe's
81 tomorrow's the anniversary of wilt's
100.
do you think we'll have somebody get to
80 if anybody can do it i think it could
be
james kyrie kd
steph devin booker
those are all the names that come to
mind right now that could probably
surpass that yeah 81 is a
that's a big number it is a big number
i always wondered though like what do
you because wilt did it and he was the
biggest guy back then and they just fed
him the ball but
do you think you could have gone for 100
i would have to be shooting 75 percent
from the free-throw line
yeah because wilt was 28 to 32 in that
game from the line
when you had 100. i would have i would
have to have a great night
i would have to have a lot of three
seconds calls not called
i would have to have a lot of easy
points
and i'll have to have no double or
triple team it would be possible
yeah that that wouldn't happen uh what
are you wearing by the way on wednesday
night
cause i'm not gonna disrespect the
wrestlers by trying to
do what they do i'm not a wrestler world
oh okay so you can't wear like the
tights like the british bulldogs
like you can't i can but i don't want to
disrespect the wrestlers i have a lot of
respect for the wrestlers they're
tremendous athletes i don't want to take
their shine on
i don't want people to think i'm mocking
this sport so this is a fight i'm coming
to
his world and my fight close uh what's
the coolest thing in the room there with
you uh
let me see i got all my trophies up
there
see ya yup looks pretty good
when my father passed away he was a
military drill sergeant that's his flag
they folded it so always keep that with
me my mvp
i think that's my rookie of the year
trophy right there and
see you should have another mvp in there
shaq it's in steve nash's house
hey steve
[Laughter]
did you ever say anything to him about
that mvp
no no i'll do it for you
i have a question for you okay most
valuable player
right yeah it's it's supposed to be
singular right so why do people say
whichever team has the best records not
most liable routines most likely
i always thought most viable player was
the guy with
the most valuable stats not about the
guy who has the best record
because i think i lost his team twice
because their record was bad
but jack if you said player of the year
then that would be different than most
valuable i think
and then you might you might have people
vote differently if it was for player of
the year not most valuable player
so most liberal players should be
rewarded
for the guy that has the best stats
on the team that has the best record but
you know the media loves a great story
shack that's why when
you know the greek freak is not going to
win the mvp this year no matter how
great he is
um they want a good story like lebron
is a good story it's been like seven
years james harden
now going to a new team maybe mvp yeah
but what about steph curry
well i i no that was my pick to start
the year but i thought if klay thompson
stayed healthy they were going to
compete for a championship
but well i never understood what
how they voted for the martial player
and i think steph curry i don't know if
you agree with me i think steph curry
is the most influential basketball
player
of the last 30 years because
he's given everybody hope that they
could play in the nba
i'm watching these little kids now yeah
and i'm like bro i've never seen a
little kid do
dribble like that shoot like that yes
i would agree because i can't be like
you and i can't be like mike
but there's a chance i might be able to
shoot like steph
yes they give us hope they give us hope
uh good luck on wednesday night it's
always great to talk to you i don't i'm
going to go out on a limb and i think
you're going to win
on wednesday night i know i'm going to
win oh you are you know you're going to
win
yes this is a fight i'm not gonna lose
but what
whatever it takes for me to win but i
gotta do pull out some little
you know uh dirty moves okay
yeah yeah hell yes i don't blame you uh
thank you shaq great to talk to you uh
what are we doing a movie again have you
talked to adam
uh well sandman did that basketball one
which one he he shot one it's not done
yet
oh he didn't ask you about being in the
no
last movie i did with him was the uh qb
halloween
yeah yeah yeah me too i'll miss you
brother
i'm thinking happy gilmore two
hey whatever whatever i had a region on
there you could be
hey you could be his catty all right yes
shaq caddy
[Laughter]
thank you thank you bud that's uh
shaquille o'neal wednesday night he
enters the ring the all-elite wrestling
taking on former tnt champ cody rhodes
in a mixed tag team match on aew
dynamite live on tnt at eight eastern